[Musique]
cette semaine en quatre la disparition
de julie bureau
comment démêler le vrai du faux regardez
le journal j'ai regardé la télévision
j'ai jamais vu aucune photo de moi j'ai
jamais vu que j'étais recherché 7 c'est
pas dans le coup à vous l'avez pas dit
un non j'ai fait un jour qu'elle est pas
si mal on dit j'ai tellement fait un
saut je n'ai pas pourquoi qu'il
révolution
à la télévision c'est impossible parce
que il ya eu tellement de publicité
autour de julie bureau dans tous les
médias bienvenue en quête les personnes
qui disparaissent laisse autour d'elle
une foule de questions qui restent
souvent sans réponse dans notre premier
reportage
nous nous intéressons à l'histoire de
julie bureau sa fugue a captivé le
québec pendant des mois les québécois on
suit la quête pour retrouver cette
adolescente de 14 ans disparus sans
laisser de traces un cas exceptionnel
puisque on l'a retrouvé vivant et en
santé trois ans plus tard mais avons
nous eu la vraie histoire en 4 sur
l'énigme de julie bureau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il élève des lamas dans un des plus
beaux paysages de la beauce
regardez les bien vous les connaissez
elle c'est julie bureau une adolescente
portée disparue pendant trois ans si
j'ai choisi de fuguer holden suicider
c'est parce que j'étais pas heureux
c'est parce que j'étais vraiment peur
j'ai jamais regretté ma fille lui c'est
jean paul bernard celui que tout le
québec a surnommé le bon samaritain
tous les deux ont été au coeur d'une
importante histoire de fugue
on l'a vraiment chercher julie bo c'est
un gros cas au québec leur histoire à
tous deux films à suspense cette jeune
femme a vécu sous trois identités
julie bureau lentz et saint-pierre et
cindy bella une histoire où on ne sait
pas où s'arrête la vérité et où commence
le mensonge
[Musique]
septembre 2001 julie bureau se sauve de
son collège privé et la 14 ans et les
vues pour la dernière fois dans ce mec
donald aquatiques en estrie puis plus
trace bonjour tout le monde merci d'être
venus je suis en or malgré ses moyens
responsable du doigt aussi concernant la
disparition de julie
on accueille deux tests à la fugue il ya
aussi une possibilité que ce soit un
vilain pense que les gens au québec ont
eu beaucoup beaucoup d'empathie pour les
parents pour ce qu'ils vivaient pas ce
que c'est
c'est impensable de vivre ça c'est de
vivre la disparition d'un d'un enfant
pendant aussi longtemps sans savoir si
elles étaient torturés seul été violée
et solide c'est l'été et tué puis que tu
cherches un corps tu cherche quelque
chose c'est pas tous les jours tu vis
seule touchée par l'angoissent d'hubert
le documentariste le côté s'intéresse au
cas de julie bureau
alors qu'ils tournent un film sur des
disparitions dans le monde
sa caméra suit pendant un an l'enquète
des policiers et saisit le drame des
parents c'est du sud c'était vraiment
vraiment difficile et je le voyais il
fouillait nous aussi fouiller les
buissons avec un bout de bois pressé de
loin de trouver finalement poids le
corps de sa fille
on cherche midi
la fête jusqu'au 6
51 jours après sa disparition
l'enquète se déplace à la télévision un
million de québécois regardent français
le poulain supplié sa fille de donner
signe de vie sur l'île hoste nos
responsabilités peut compter sur la
terre mais [ __ ] je peux pas nous
laisser tomber les pistes des enquêteurs
ne mène nulle part
les mois s'écoulent puis les années on
la croit morte
sauf sa meilleure amie j'ai jamais
vraiment pensé qu est tellement je suis
a tout tenté une fille courageuse
ponceuse puis je dans ma tête c'était
comme un espace de groupe une marilyn et
julie se connaissent depuis le primaire
mais toujours à trouver le moyen de s'en
sortir
elle n'avait pas tort trois ans après la
disparition de julie alors que cette
histoire était tombé dans l'oubli
julie est reconnue dans ce marché aux
puces vous faites le tour au moins demi
heure de temps certain et puis là elle
est partie il est arrivé donc madame ici
a dit est-ce que vous la connaissez
j'ai dit non première fois que je la
vois m'a dit c'est julie bureau asie
elle avait disparu ce signalement permet
à la police de retracer enfin julie
bureau pendant qu ont remué ciel et
terre pour la retrouver
elle habitait à une heure de chez ses
parents chez cet homme
jean paul bernard au long des fous rires
des jsi vingt sept se vend bien
lorsqu'on est un conteur seniors à
retrouver l'eau la vie est belle
quelques jours plus tard en conférence
de presse on découvre julie bureau
déterminer qui étonne par ses propos
l'opinion des gens l'eau sans mostro du
les gens diront qu est-ce qui voudront
savent pas ils savent pas ma vie n'est
on pas d'affaires à savoir que regarder
le journal je regardais la télévision
j'ai jamais vu aucune photo de moi j'ai
jamais vu que j'étais recherché
comment est ce possible julie va bientôt
avoir 18 ans la dpj nous confirme qu'à
l'époque elle considérait que sa
sécurité n'était pas menacée avec
l'accord de ses parents julie retourne
donc vivre avec jean-paul bernard celui
qu'on appelle désormais le bon
samaritain donc les médias ont surnommé
puis je n'accepte pas ce que je pense
que j'ai sauvé la vie comment on appelle
un bon samaritain quelqu'un qui prend
une fille de 14 ans chez lui 15 ans et
ai dit que si jamais préoccupé de son
large
c'est quand même une chose soucis et
deuxièmement laquelle pas d'autres vies
et le porte parole a rien là qui se
passe autour
et c'est toi qui s'en occupent tu la
protèges et tout ça je pense qu'il faut
être très naïf traîne à effet est
pourquoi les médias ont été aussi naïf
en même temps à cette époque là
je voulais sortir aller puis il expliqué
au monde qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
pourquoi j'écris un lycée pour que la
ville d assaut à peine cinq mois après
avoir été retrouvé celle qui souhaitait
vivre à l'ombre des média publie son
histoire une charge contre sa mère qui
est un responsable de sa fugue
c'était beaucoup du harcèlement
psychologique autant c'est fait
physiquement moralement moralement
c'était extrêmement dur parce que
c'était havas pouvait morcelé partout le
elle va vendre des entrevues aux médias
puis un deuxième livre paraît le bon
samaritain
selon elle son histoire lui aurait
rapporté autour de 75 mille dollars
je voyais vraiment ça comme un coup de
marketing un coup de publicité et puis
ça s'est passé très vite tout simple on
a essayé de profiter de le faire depuis
le début de cette affaire il est
difficile de distinguer le vrai du faux
julie bureau a accepté de nous
rencontrer chez elle en beauce où elle
vit avec jean-paul bernard comme frères
et soeurs dit elle depuis bientôt dix
ans vous mener jusqu'à ce jour que c'est
pendant ces trois années là vous avez
vraiment vécu frères serre oui
exactement
bon j'arrête aujourd'hui au piton donne
matin pluzz charlot julie et jean-paul
ont l'air de ne manquer de rien mais de
quoi vivent t-il
la gt 19h camionneurs et que j'étais 13
en important des incendies
je suis producteur forestier également
le héros de cette histoire a aussi un
dossier criminel des vols des voies de
fait des gestes commis dans la vingtaine
c'est incroyable non qu'on les appelait
le bon samaritain et que en même temps
on s'est peu questionné davantage sur ce
single moi j'en venais pas l'époque on
ne sait pas questionner beaucoup plus
sur les circonstances entourant la fille
de julie bureau car qu'on décide de
fuguer on sait pas quelle conséquence on
s'expose développer en place à 14 en
valeur ont ce point commun que la vie
marche à l'été 2001 elle clavardent avec
un étranger qui vient la chercher à
coaticook à la sortie d'école aux
émetteurs boulot qu'elle allait avoir
des beaux vêtements et autres cascades
plus beau pour une jeune fille c'est la
fuite vers montréal au début j'avais
pour voir mais après quand gervais à
montréal j'ai compris que ce qui se
passait là selon ce qu'elle nous raconte
elle se serait retrouvée prisonnière
d'un réseau de prostitution
un enfer qui aurait duré trois semaines
ormond violé dès le premier soir ils
m'ont attaché
j'étais sûr qu'ils allaient me tuer le
genre n'est pas que ça existait des
afghans même quand j'ai eu la chance de
mourir je me suis enfui des événements
traumatisants
si ce sont vraiment déroulé moi je me
mets moi de son histoire de montréal
j'ai su que ça devient quelque chose de
plus excitant lui inquiété kidnapped et
à montréal la prostitution la drogue
tout seul selon la version de julie sa
cavale se poursuivre elle fut morial en
auto stop et se retrouve en bronze
c'est là qu'elle rencontre son bon
samaritain jean paul bernard qu'il avait
montée dans son auto
cette nuit là sur cette route de
campagne
julie bureau devient même si saint
pierre m'a demandé mon nom j'ai dit je
m'appelais nancy saint pierre
j'avais 18 ans puis j'ai toujours
fonctionné avec cette entité lol tout le
temps que j'étais à feu et pour personne
qui a su chi que j'étais réellement
personne pas même l'homme qui l'héberge
pendant trois ans je ne suis pas dans le
coup à vous l'avez pas dit maintenant
j'ai fait un choc à l'épaule c'est mal
on dit j'ai tellement fait un show est
ce que vous le croyez lui quand il dit
qu'il savait pas que c'était julie
bureau
non moi je peux pas de quoi tu peux pas
quoi comme je peux pas croire julie non
plus comme par exemple lorsqu'elle dit
qu'elle ignorait qu on la cherchait
[Musique]
ses anciennes amies marilyn et david n'y
crois pas j'ai déjà vu sa maison ou à ce
qu'elle vit présentement la gare aux
télévisions qui avait alors avec un beau
s'étaler sur le toit je n'ai pas
pourquoi qu'il répond plus haut à la
télévision c'est impossible parce que il
ya eu tellement de publicité autour de
julie d'euros dans tous les médias et de
dire qu'il n'était pas au courant et
tout ça non j'ai jamais j'ai jamais
acheté cette histoire les recherches
dans le bois vous n'avez pas vu sa
télévision n'ont rien vu d'autre part
votre mère qui parlait
la conférence de presse quand ils sont
allés à une émission car la marche vous
exploitiez pas télévision oui j'écoute à
la télévision oui j'écoute une nouvelle
régulièrement
puis j'ai pas du tout non mais comment
ignorer que ses parents la chercher est
ce que ça vous arrive est de penser
pendant ces trois années là que vos
parents étaient morts d'inquiétude
ben ça m'est déjà arrivé d'y penser mais
je savais que si je leur ai donné une
nouvelle quoique ce soit il m'aurait
retracer soit sur la majorité des
fugueurs appel ou sont retrouvés dans un
délai de 48 heures devant le silence de
julie la sûreté du québec a poursuivi
les recherches
trois ans après sa disparition des
plongeurs fouillent encore des rivières
en estrie la sûreté du québec n'a pas
voulu chiffrer le montant des recherches
mais on peut avancer que l' enquête pour
retrouver julie bureau a coûté des
dizaines de milliers de dollars aux
québécois
julie ne s'en est jamais soucié mais
revenons sur les événements qui se
seraient déroulées à montréal après
avoir été agressé julie me dit qu'elle
n'avait qu'un but retrouver ses
agresseurs fois les jeux mac réinvente
une entité sociale pour faire mon
enquête pour faire son enquête julie
bureau alias nenci saint-pierre prend
une autre identité
sidibé la masseuse érotique elle espère
ainsi qu'un de ses agresseurs de
montréal va mordre la mission et la
contacter donc j'ai pensé des annonces
sur internet comme de quoi que
j'offrirai des massages érotiques
vous étiez prêts à vous prostituées avec
ces gars là pour retrouver mon agresseur
oui je suis prêt je veux la retrouver un
des cas c'est vraiment important
avez vous coucher avec des gars ici qui
sont venus j'ai déjà eu j'ai déjà offert
des massages et des ja oui ça m'est déjà
arrivé aussi parce que j'avais vraiment
doutes sérieux que ça pouvait être une
des personnes que j'ai rencontrées à
montréal
cindy aurait rencontré une dizaine
d'hommes à domicile entre 2005 et 2008
si vous vous étiez d'accord avec un
registre a chjama dakar parce que je
savais c'est pas une quarantaine
cinquantaine de personnes qu'ils
rencontrent et je savais c'est juste
quelques pièces que vous étiez conscient
que ces gaulois venait ici puisqu'elle
avait des relations sexuelles alors oui
jma peut-être pas toutes à des relations
sexuelles mais j'étais conscient qu'il
menait des purs étrangers
sa seule afin que j'aime et pau kidal et
purs étrangers dans ma maison
curieux pour quelqu'un qui nous
affirmons entrevue vouloir la protéger
je lui donne une bonne qualité de vie à
ce titre il a juste 23 ans c'est aka la
prensa veut faire de quoi la vie moi je
suis parti je l'aimé alors remis dans le
droit chemin en mars 2008
cindy bella alias ben si saint pierre
alias julie bureau donne rendez-vous à
un client de québec
l'histoire va prendre une autre tournure
rocambolesque ont fait qu'on a eu une
relation sexuelle
alors finalement après la relation
sexuelle j'ai vu la porte de chambre qui
s'est ouverte doucement et j'ai vu
jean-paul dans le cloud de la porte de
champ les prenons sur le fait jean paul
bernard menace le client de prévenir sa
femme son employeur et les médias et
exigent un montant d'argent pour son
silence
quelques jours plus tard il revient à la
charge et laisse ce message menaçant
dans la boîte vocale du client nous en
reproduisons ici un extrait
salut on est rendu le dis toujours pas
de nouvelles
re donné jusqu'à fin de la journée pour
y penser
ausy évidente remis mes pensées
[Musique]
le client dénonce jean paul bernard à la
police le bon samaritain est accusé
d'extorsion
il y à procès lors du procès julie et
jean-paul soutiennent qu'il n'y a jamais
eu d'extorsion et que celle clients
qu'il aura offert 14 mai dollars pour
des objets qu'ils auraient volé lors de
sa rencontre avec cindy c'est beaucoup
d'argent s'il y avait eu peur aussi que
vous disiez à sa femme ce qui faisait
ici juste pour acheter l'assurance de
gens pour kia qui a offert ce parce
qu'il y avait commis un vol y sommes
bien voir c'est grave
julie explique au juge pourquoi il se
prostituent si elle offre des massages
érotiques c'est pour retrouver ses
agresseurs le procureur semble douter de
cette version dans son interrogatoire
que nous reprenons ici vos agresseurs je
comprends qu'ils étaient dans la région
de montréal
vous vous vous prostituées dans la
région de bordj pour retrouver des
agresseurs de la région montréal le juge
n'en croit pas un mot et considère
l'histoire farfelue
dans son jugement il conclut que le
client a été piégé est menacée dans le
but de fournir une rançon et ce par
l'accusé bernard avec la complicité du
jury d'euros
mais julie bureau n'a jamais été accusé
le bon samaritain lui écope d'un an de
prison ferme
compte tenu de ses antécédents
judiciaires julie se retrouve seul à
beauceville
avec sa vérité moi j'ai compté la vérité
du début jusqu'à la fin
je suis allé en cours j'ai témoigné j'ai
raconté la vérité du début jusqu'à la
fin
est-ce qu'on a eu au québec la vraie
histoire le vrai l'histoire de julie
bureau mais je pense que
ses parents me disent encore cet avenir
c'est à venir il espère toujours la
revoir revenir
vous voyez pas pour vivre l'homme et de
la revoir aux folies bien son mandat de
revoir leur julie de l'époque
[Musique]